and back then they were like what are
you doing this before you're like oh i'm
going to go fight in a cage with
somebody they're like what the [ __ ] this
yeah
yeah back then i like i just spent a lot
of time promoting people and ex
promoting the sport and trying to figure
trying to explain to people what the
sport was but man do you do you have to
train for that
like you just get off the barstool and
just go
that was a normal question yeah yeah
that was like and it wasn't like they
weren't trying to be dicks they were
just like man do you have to train for
that just just get up and get off the
part and god's wanting to get mad at
somebody go go fight like
i guess you could do that but yeah we do
train a little bit out here yeah
could you ever at that time like foresee
how big the ufc has gotten now no i
always thought it would be get this big
i just thought it would take a lot
longer to get there and i think that
that what what happened was like really
what the big thing was our trojan horse
dan was first hosting a live fight on tv
was
was a reality show and that reality show
crazy is what really prove it because
we got no because it was really hard to
break into uh people like like younger
people were understanding that or
understand the sport like breaking into
like some of these companies and getting
in some of these executives that guide
the top like
that's that's
that's not good stuff
no one wants to see that but when we got
like it's like when those
fighters started going and they started
doing the show and the ratings that they
got
were like wait a minute people are
watching this
yeah and then and then that fight i mean
you could ask for a better like uh was
it forced griffin was the first
foreigner was that that first you know
final main event or first uh like like
five all right for uh for that show and
it was like first live fight on tv you
know it's like
we couldn't ask for a better fight i
mean it's like a goddess type you know
like guys going out and just they were
and they you know they're doing
mixed martial arts stuff that it wasn't
just like a striking or
too much wrestling it was a mix
everything so
it was such a great fight for it you
know
brilliant when people ask me did you
think jackass would blow up and become
as big as it was
like i always say
i i understood that it would be popular
i just didn't think it would be allowed
on tv to become popular you know that
was like the
i just figured like how are you gonna
show the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that we do like
it's not like what we do isn't allowed
on tv right and uh the kind of the same
thing with the ufc is that the the
problem wasn't whether it would be
popular enough to become as big as it is
it just would they [ __ ] show it you
know and and that's been a little bit of
an uphill battle and it was like what
what do you think broke down the
barriers
i just i mean it was just
you know it's like anything else ratings
the ratings
wanted maybe
once they were able to get and show how
many people really wanted to watch this
like oh
okay
well now dana's talking about getting on
cbs not abc and he's already had one on
abc so it's already had one they've got
another one coming up
and that was the one who's trying to get
hamza and colby on
i feel like you also got to give joe
rogan a lot of credit because like for
someone like me who's like not really
following the fc but i hear him talk
about it and the art of it and like the
intricacies of it it kind of makes me
look at it more as like not just some
violent crazy thing but yeah
i mean he's not make smarter strongest
in his own right
yeah good jiu jitsu guy
did kickboxing was kickboxing guy i mean
didn't he start out in taekwondo i think
and then taekwondo went out a little bit
and then he'd i think he's an instructor
for taekwondo yeah
i mean yeah i would like to see him in
the the ufc hall of fame i mean there's
got to be a spot for joe rogan in there
it's i mean absolutely and it's a really
good point that joe rogan
did so much for the sport
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]